can you tell us how you Hoodwinked CNN
that's so great yeah can you break down
how you stole money favorite thing yeah
right we can get into the we can get
into all the intimacies of that yeah
um especially now that my NDA is up oh
really here we go let's go ask oh fire
away okay so you create this tech
company yeah okay you are how old at
this time 35 minutes or 36. you were
already vlogging yeah okay you're
already married yep by this time you
have two kids yep two kids sure and so
you're just trying to find ways to just
be away from the family what is the
purpose of this tech company what is the
real core purpose of it I mean like the
actual history of of the like the
inspiration behind the tech companies I
was at um I was invited to MIT as a
fellow like the MIT media lab as a
fellow which was a big deal because I'm
a high school dropout yeah into the best
of my professors knowledge I'm the only
both High School Dropout who is also an
invited at MIT
um I still carry my MIT ID it's in my
wallet my office
um did you graduate high school no
straight to MIT that's exactly right as
an Indian that's the thing in your
career I'm most jealous of yeah you
graduated MIT
um
and when I was there like I really I
like stopped making videos I just
enveloped myself into that world and I
worked with a group called The Social
Computing Group which was like super you
know it was about coding and the social
implications of software in 2015. I read
this amazing book by Nick Bilton called
hatching Twitter which was about sort of
the birth of Twitter where they get into
the fact that like at its Inception the
guys that were starting Twitter were
just kind of these Knuckleheads who had
an idea they hobbled it together and it
became Twitter and I was like you know
I'm like I have ideas and like I I
realize that MIT like I don't just
because I don't know how to write code
doesn't mean I can't realize this and I
had this idea for like a video products
is when like videos I thought social
media rather was getting really gross
and it was all about filters and lying
and like I could create something that's
really honest
and I found like this amazing partner
and this guy named Matt Hackett who he
was like the the CTO or the head of uh I
don't know what his title was but he's
very senior at Tumblr super capable like
unbelievably brilliant technologist he
became my partner we raised Venture
money and we built this product it was
called beam it was originally called be
me
because the idea was like you post
videos that are unfiltered and raw and
people get to experience sort of your
life through your perspective and it was
awesome and it was great and it was like
uh that was part of the idea behind the
Vlogs like I can use my Vlog to talk
about this company it's just not that
interesting like a bunch of dudes
sitting around coding but once we
launched the product it became like
there's such Synergy between the Vlog
and the product and we had this wildly
successful launch and like an
unbelievable amount of people downloaded
the app and loved it and used it but
ultimately like Snapchat was better and
Snapchat like this is right when
Snapchat stories came out when Snapchat
stories came out I'm like well this is
like what we built but better in every
[__] way like they're really this is
so good and ours man yeah
I was like [__] this is so much better
than what we built yeah and you know
we've pivoted we did a bunch of stuff we
built a really strong Community we built
a really strong but ultimately like the
app just did not succeed but the funny
thing about the tech space is like just
because your product fails doesn't mean
you don't have something of value and I
met with Jeff sucker at uh CNN because
his son was a fan of mine I remember
like at the time so I was daily vlogging
like I had to rule no meetings and my
agent called me he's like I have a
meeting for you I was like I can't
afford a [__] meeting I have to make
a video every day yeah he's like this
one you might want to take it's the head
of CNN I was like okay and I met with
them and Jeff was like how can we work
together and he's like a super cool guy
and I was like oh there's no way I got
my own thing and I'm bigger than you are
more people watch my Vlogs and watch CNN
like I'm happy there and then like as I
was like you know what though your
technology sucks
I was like CNN has bad Tech your app is
like
[__] like late 2000s app like your
website looks like something that's like
belongs on AOL like it's [__]
terrible I was like There's an
opportunity there and he handed me off
to his people who were very smart and we
got excited like let's buy your company
and they weren't buying an app because
the app was not successful they're just
buying the tech behind it they were
buying the tech behind they're buying
this amazing team that we had built
they're buying like access to Matt my
partner buying access to me and my
insight and like we had all these ideas
together and like that's how they bought
my company for like a lot of money yeah
can we say how much
but maybe it just comes out of your mail
but it's 200 million I wish I wish um
damn I thought that was gonna make you
so like the number that was public was
25 million and then what's the private
number that was that was good wow that
was well-worded sentence that's the
public number 25 million yeah do you get
a trip anywhere crazy do they take you
to some like wild sex parties Anderson
Cooper's Epstein's Island yeah no I will
say they acquired the company like
and right as we were getting up to speed
we went to South by Southwest and I was
like the keynote speaker at South by and
CNN had this huge event like that not a
huge party to like celebrate and talk
what we're doing together and stuff and
I remember I was like all the executives
were there like I was like how long are
you guys here for like how we're all
going back tonight
and I'm like you're like flying back I
was like it's too late and they're like
no no we got like the CNN plan we're
flying back tonight
and I was like can I go with you and I
didn't get I said no I didn't get to go
on the CNN plane
what now hold on hold on one second hold
on one second Casey you know there was
an extra I would have sat in the
bathroom yeah you've been on pjs you
know in the bathroom you could there's a
thing you put over the toilet and
there's a seat belt I don't sit in the
bathroom above that just bring me back
snacks yeah it's almost better actually
in the bathroom yeah it's a private room
and then if someone needs to use it I
would step out get out go back and bring
the snacks out 100 and then when they
were done I'll go back in clean yep and
then I'll eat my snacks now you harbored
this feeling of rejection I still do but
how did you get around it how did you
overcome overcome not being the
president what was the first thing that
you did once you got that big deal what
is the first thing that you and your
family did
you started doing this once you got that
big CNN deal what was it you know I
don't how did you guys start flying
around the world Casey
what'd you do Aaron eistat I bought my
own 737 business take that CNN
it's parked outside right now wow why
are you taxing over here yeah oh nice
dude none of this is true
skateboard here no did you start flying
private afterwards okay like this is a
fun story yeah I I like I remember
because that was like that was the year
like like the CNN and not only like Not
only was there that payout but like they
hired Matt and I we had salary I was on
Saturday
and like also that was when it was like
raining with YouTube money and it was
the first time in my life yeah that I
had money yeah and like I was like when
my first kid was born I was [__] 16
years I was on welfare yeah like my
first apartment in New York City was an
SRO a halfway house where I bribed the
guy at the front with the 100 Bill and a
carton of cigarettes to give me a room I
had no bathroom and no kitchen and it
was just [__] like he doesn't even
know he's not gonna cross out yeah
[__] up [__] happened in there like
[__] up [__] happened they're like I
would live in there with my kid I
remember going to the bathroom once with
my kid he was like two years old and I
have to go to the potty and it's like we
have to put our shoes on we have to take
like our basket with all of our
toiletries and we go to the bathroom
[__] bathroom was covered in blood
you know I like close the door so we
didn't see it I was like come on up here
to the other bathroom or go down a
flight of steps like that was my life
wow so like boom all of a sudden like I
get paid so like I remember saying to my
wife I was like look this is gonna end
but like I mean we're gonna like while
it's happening
like we went and bought an apartment and
then like we didn't get a 737 or
whatever I said two minutes ago but like
we like got like a thing where you get
to go on a plane for like you like rent
hours yeah yeah Snapchats or whatever
like that but it was like like once
we're like we're in Miami and our kid
was sick and I was like
I'll get us their own plane to go home
it was like 8 000 bucks [__] I wish I
had the 8 000 bucks right now but it was
[__] fun
but it was fun